You’re a member of an elite Mobile Task
Force, tracking down an anomaly in a rural
village somewhere in the Swiss Alps that was
recently detected by SCP Foundation Field
Agents.
According to all the current intel, you’re
dealing with a particularly deadly and hard-to-contain
monster: A shapeshifting entity that can kill
with a touch, and assume the form of anyone
it kills.
If this thing somehow escaped the village
and broke into a major population center,
it could blend in perfectly and cause death
on a massive scale.
It’s up to you and your team to get this
creature secured and contained before that
can happen.
You’re going in heavily armed, with advanced
sensory technology and several attack helicopters,
each one loaded with plenty of powerful missiles.
One way or another, you’re putting a stop
to this thing.
But the best laid plans of Mobile Task Force
agents go often awry.
The mission is a bloodbath - the shapeshifting
anomaly has blended in perfectly with the
innocent civilians living in the village.
Before you know it, half of your team have
been killed, and you don’t know which of
the remaining team members are really themselves.
This really couldn’t have gone worse, and
if you mess this up, not only is your life
at risk, but so are the lives of everyone
this anomaly happens to get close to.
All of your superiors were killed or transformed
in the battle with the shapeshifter, and you’re
now sitting at the top of your MTF’s chain
of command.
The way you see it, there’s only one option.
You radio up to air support, alerting the
several attack choppers circling the village.
You tell them to rain fire and destroy the
whole place; that’s the only way to be sure
to take out the anomaly.
Things have gone beyond the point of easy
containment.
You sprint past the village limits as a volley
of missiles and firebombs raze the formerly-quiet
settlement to the ground.
Other than the Task Force members in the helicopters,
you’re the only survivor.
Over 320 people are dead.
But on the upside, the remains of the shapeshifting
anomaly were found amongst the rubble by Foundation
personnel.
You prevented whatever horrors it would have
caused if it had been allowed to escape.
Mission accomplished.
But it’s not over yet.
When you solemnly return to the Containment
Site you’d been deployed from, your superiors
order you to go pay a visit to Conference
Room 2.
You correctly assume that it’s some kind
of disciplinary meeting - maybe the Site Director
chewing you out for shoddy work, but ultimately
congratulating you for doing what needed to
be done under pressure.
After all, making the tough decisions is what
working for the SCP Foundation is all about.
But when you arrive in the Conference Room,
you’re sitting across from a woman you’ve
never seen before.
She’s tall, with hard, stern-looking features,
and a plain but well-tailored suit.
Despite being a hardened soldier on the Foundation
payroll, something about this woman makes
you nervous.
She smiles, and says:
“Hello, I’m with the Foundation Ethics
Committee.
We need to have a word.”
For reasons you don’t quite understand,
you start to break into a cold sweat.
The Ethics Committee?
I thought they existed just to scare Foundation
employees.
I didn’t know they had actual authority.
But that’s where you made a terrible mistake.
And from the tight smile on the agent’s
face, you can tell that the Foundation Ethics
Committee has a lot more power than you’ve
ever imagined.
Perhaps you know them from the jokes that
float around Foundation circles - “How many
members of the Ethics Committee does it take
to change a lightbulb?
None!
The Ethics Committee can't change anything!”
Perhaps you’ve heard about the O5 Council’s
disdain for them, those bureaucratic pencil-pushers
with all their rubber stamps and red tape.
The jokes don’t seem so funny now though.
The Ethics Committee representative clears
her throat, and tells you that you’re being
reassigned, effective immediately.
You’re now under the employ of the Foundation
Ethics Committee, and this change is non-negotiable.
You try to state your case in a blind panic.
Part of you thinks being “reassigned to
the Ethics Committee'' after the mistake you
just made is code for “being taken into
a windowless room and shot in the back of
your head.”
But the agent insists that really isn’t
the case - the Ethics Committee hates codes
and euphemisms.
They don’t say “terminated”, they say
“killed.”
Because at the Ethics Committee, clarity of
language is extremely important.
They don’t sanitize any horrific acts that
need to be performed for the sake of containment
- After all, it’s their job to look these
horrors in the face, and give the final “Yes''
or “No” on whether they’re carried out.
As you may know, the SCP Foundation is essentially
above all external law.
No government, no organization, and no individual
can tell them what to do.
The thirteen members of the O5 Council have
almost unlimited knowledge at their disposal,
as well as technology that the rest of the
world could only ever dream of.
With a setup like that, it would be easy to
give into corruption and go mad with power.
If they wanted to, they could abandon their
mission of protecting humanity from the shadows,
and instead rule the world with an iron fist.
That’s where the all-important role of the
Foundation Ethics Committee comes in.
As Uncle Ben once said, “with great power
comes great responsibility.”
Just as the O5 Council wields the power, the
Ethics Committee wields the responsibility.
They remind the whole organization that they
are here to serve the world, not the other
way around.
Think of them as the conscience of the SCP
Foundation - they decide what’s morally
acceptable for the Foundation to do in pursuit
of its goals, to make sure that those who
fight monsters don’t become monsters themselves.
As Nietzsche famously said, “if you gaze
long into an abyss, the abyss also gazes into
you.”
Right now, you very much feel like you’re
staring into the abyss, as the Ethics Committee
representative calmly explains the situation
to you.
An important thing to remember about the Foundation
is that it must be cold, not cruel.
The second that the harm it causes is in excess
of the positive results of the Foundation’s
actions, it’s time for the Ethics Committee
to step in and dole out some discipline.
It is the Ethics Committee’s job to balance
the moral cost of every action performed by
the Foundation - from the degree of collateral
damage permissible in the field, to the ways
that D-Classes can be ethically used in testing.
While some hardcore Foundation loyalists may
say that people like the Ethics Committee
are standing in the way of true progress,
giving yourself wholly to the mission without
any ethical safeguards can be a dangerous
line to walk.
At that point, what’s separating the Foundation
from the Global Occult Coalition or the Chaos
Insurgency?
Or even worse, their nightmarish alternate
selves from the universes of SCP-1730 and
SCP-5000?
While the Foundation occasionally needs to
do some truly horrific things in order to
Secure, Contain, and Protect, it’s the Ethics
Committee that keeps them on the moral high
ground.
All of this seems pretty complicated to you,
as you sit, still fearing for your life in
Conference Room 2.
The Ethics Committee agent explains that it’s
actually all quite simple, once you get used
to it.
The Ethics Committee uses a moral framework
known as Utilitarianism - Think of it like
the product of morality and math.
Specifically, the Committee uses an ethical
system known as Negative Utilitarianism.
This system revolves around the principle
of “Harm Reduction” - the Committee tries
to modify every action taken to cause the
least amount of possible suffering in a situation.
The goal being to eliminate any unnecessary
suffering from an action.
“Take your decision, for example,” the
Ethics Committee representative says.
“Your actions - namely, the destruction
of the village - caused a great deal of suffering.
However, considering the damage the anomaly
could have caused after your team lost control
of the situation, it’s clear that your motivation
was ultimately pure harm-reduction.
I admire that kind of thinking in a high-pressure
situation.”
You feel a cool wave of relief wash over you.
It feels safe to assume at this point that
this probably isn’t just a big front for
your immediate termination.
The agent sitting across from you seems to
sense that that’s what you’re thinking,
and assures you that she’s being nothing
but honest with you.
The Ethics Committee has no need to be petty
- They know everything, after all.
And that’s not an exaggeration - Their clearance
is basically the equivalent to Level 5, the
highest in the Foundation.
Every line ever redacted from an SCP Foundation
file, they were privy to.
Every secret the Foundation has ever kept,
they have absolute access to.
And every decision the Foundation has ever
made?
The Ethics Committee has always had the final
say - with veto power even over the O5 Council.
And most importantly, all members of the Ethics
Committee are former Foundation personnel
- Site Directors, Researchers, Mobile Task
Force operatives.
All people whose decisions have caused pain
and death.
Much like jury duty, the responsibility is
random and non-negotiable.
What you’re experiencing right now isn’t
a normal disciplinary hearing - it’s an
employee orientation.
The cruel irony, for a department of the Foundation
devoted to ethical conduct, is that it’s
actually complicit in pretty much all of the
Foundation’s worst moral crimes.
After all, every action that the Foundation
has ever performed has been performed with
the permission and cooperation of the Ethics
Committee.
Take the infamous Procedure 110-Montauk, used
to prevent the victims of SCP-231 giving birth.
The Ethics Committee had a key role in designing
the horrific procedure, and now, they have
to live with the soul-crushing knowledge of
exactly what that procedure entails.
And soon, you will too.
Just one of the many “perks” of joining
the committee.
“It isn’t the easiest job,” the representative
tells you.
She’s got the steely, blank eyes of someone
who’s seen some things that people were
never meant to see.
She continues, “Before we conclude the first
part of your orientation, I suppose I should
tell you about the Sowing Circle.
That’ll give you a good idea of what you’re
in for.”
She tells you that the Sowing Circle was the
anomaly discussed in the 2017 Ethics Committee
Roundtable.
It’s an anomaly so secretive that it was
never given an official containment number
or classification, but it was proposed as
a solution to one of the Foundation’s most
nightmarish problems: The shortage of human
infants.
It’s an ugly truth about the Foundation
that a decent number of anomalies - such as
SCP-2845, the Deer - require the sacrifice
of live children as part of their containment
procedures.
For years, the Foundation had been stealing
children from orphanages for the use in these
rituals, but the Sowing Circle could solve
this problem: It was a mummified human corpse,
wreathed in a circle of its own dried-out
intestines.
The mummy produced seeds which, if consumed,
could allow human women to produce litters
of twelve babies with an eight hour gestation
period, like the litters of a sow - hence
the name.
This would solve the baby shortage handily.
It was the job of the Ethics Committee to
decide what would be the most ethical way
to use this anomaly.
In the end, despite their own personal, moral
disgust at the actions, their philosophy of
harm reduction led them to one conclusion:
Using the device to impregnate already brain-dead
patients, effectively turning them into comatose
infant factories whose only purpose was to
be used in horrific containment procedures.
But ultimately, the sacrifice would pale compared
to the pain averted - seeing as millions,
if not billions, would be under threat from
some of these entities being released.
Not that this makes the knowledge of what
needs to be done any easier to handle on a
personal level.
But of course, after what you did at the village,
you know this feeling all too well already.
The pain and the guilt you felt at making
that decision is going to follow you your
whole life.
And now you’re about to have countless more
experiences piled on top.
It’s your burden, your duty, your job.
The Ethics Committee agent forces a weak smile.
She says, “Of course, nobody said the job
was easy, but somebody needs to do it…”
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King”
and “Secret Group that Runs the World - SCP
O5 Council Explained” for more SCP Foundation
deep lore!